and if you need any further evidence
that maybe it's not such a good idea to
disband the cops because there's no
evidence that we should do that at all
look at the leaders occasionally the
leaders break through into the
mainstream media never on the left-wing
channels but at least Fox News the
right-leaning cable news channel
interviewed one of the leaders one of
the peaceful rioters of this movement
and what do you think he was talking
about what do you think he was promoting
was he promoting this idea that we
should all go out and you know come
together and kumbaya no he was
threatening to burn down the diamond
district of New York you know I'm a
leader of this ftv movement it means a
lot of things it could mean free to
people it could be for the people it
could also mean fired to property you
know and that's very possible today I'm
leading a demonstration from Barclays
Center at 6:00 p.m. to City Hall and
that's the first stop and we're hoping
DeBlasio and Cuomo come out and talk to
us and give the youth some direction but
if they don't the next stop is a diamond
district and gasoline thanks to Trump is
awfully cheap gasoline thanks to Trump
is awfully cheap there's actually a
secondary racial component to this which
is that the diamond district in New York
is run by Jews and among the so-called
peaceful black identitarian leaders in
New York there's been a little bit of
hostility historically with the Jews
there you know I give this guy credit
the FTP movement which he says is for
the people free the people what it
really means is if the police I give him
credit for using that phrase because FTP
is a little more honest about the
radical aims and the radical tenor of
the movements a lot more honest than BLM
but all in all basically the same thing
[Music]
[Music]